hear any stories of anything
Supernatural happening no I'm glad you
asked that question about you yeah
because I remember hearing you say
something
I've never seen a dead body up close
yeah seen quite a few dead Buddies
about you I've seen one yeah me either
I'm the same boat as Scotty I mean I've
only been to a funeral where they had an
open casket so that was probably the
closest I've been to a dead body but
I've never seen somebody like on the
street or in the real world not living
uh
yeah it always seems unreal when it's in
the box and it's made up and they look
like they're sleeping or like a
mannequin or something but
yeah I'm sure it's so I I think when you
see stuff like that it is so detached
from our minds like it's you don't even
comprehend what's going on like I
remember actually when I was growing up
I used to watch some of those like face
to death movies and stuff and uh I
remember seeing them cutting off the
hand of somebody and it being on the
ground it looked like a Hollywood prop
it looked fake but it was like it's real
it looks fake because we don't see body
parts off of people so I'm sure if you
just saw somebody on the ground like
that
it almost doesn't even compute what
you're seeing really right
yeah the reality is that you know a dead
body or many dead bodies is coming to a
city near you I mean this is just the
day and age we live in is that death
When Death Becomes overwhelming the
normal process to deal with that death
is interrupted you know if you can't
have a funeral because there's hundreds
of thousands of dead bodies in the
street so now it becomes just a a
problem of Sanitation more than anything
you know how do we get these bodies
taken care of so they don't cause
problems I wonder if like movies play
into that that you just you know you
kind of just I've seen lots of movies
where they portray these things
Holocaust type movies
um but yeah it's a whole different ball
game when you see that in the real yeah
I was picturing like the Holocaust and
stuff they just had mountains of bodies
that they just just got to get them out
of the way yeah and it seems like
there's natural disasters everywhere I
mean obviously what happened in Turkey
is has happened before you know a lot of
people lost their lives in that tsunami
that's that wiped off all those uh beach
towns and stuff yeah
yeah the the destruction is getting
bigger and gnarlier and it's harder to
cope and harder to manage so where did
where did this happen where did you see
this so in Turkey this is the recent
earthquake that happened in Turkey
um this is towards the beginning of the
year and
um it was a pretty significant Quake you
know in in multiple locations that they
had these earthquakes and unfortunately
some of the I think there was 10 cities
in turkey that were affected wow and
that doesn't even include Syria which if
you know Syria is in the middle of a
civil war right now
so that was the real sad part is that
all the focus was on turkey and there
was like zero focus on Syria because
that's like the hotbed of Isis and
terrorism and so I mean that you know
when you're a terrorist Nation or a
terrorist hotbed like when you need help
that's weird I didn't hear anything
about Syria Aleppo aleppo's not too far
from hatai which is the ancient state of
Antioch and that was one of the cities
that was pretty devastated and Aleppo
was devastated by this earthquake as
well but again it's just you know
people's minds it's too dangerous to
give help in an area where they're
already fighting back and forth so real
quick just in case somebody doesn't know
who you are what you do how why are you
over there what are you doing over there
yeah so
um we we operate a small little Disaster
Response Team called the Gideon rescue
company and the simple answer as we go
where God sends us amen and so we we
know that these disasters are increasing
because what we read in Matthew 24
the disasters are going to come right on
the heel of each and every one and
earthquake specifically is listed
biblically that we're going to see
earthquakes in diverse places and we
haven't had a large-scale earthquake in
a while actually
um I think we had a few minor ones
throughout the past years or so but it's
been are you talking to us or worldwide
just worldwide you know I mean in terms
of like large loss of life I think the
last large loss of life earthquake might
have been Nepal you know where we had
you know if you remember Kathmandu
there in Nepal we had quite a big
earthquake there that killed a few
people in the U.S it was probably San
Francisco
that would have been the turn of the
century in 1900s
we were kids but I'd only knocked down a
couple things of the bridge and you know
yeah I think that happened in the 80s
maybe 90s I don't remember exactly but
yeah earthquakes are scary you know
because
um the structures that man has built
become very vulnerable especially when
you're multi-storied and that was no
exception in Turkey is that you know you
have really heavy concrete structures
maybe not quite the same coating that we
build even here but it's not just the
magnitude it's also the time that it
shakes so given you can have a small
magnitude but if it shakes for a long
time it doesn't matter what kind of
building you have it's going to
sustained damage or come down this one
shook for two minutes yeah it was a long
time and I think the average one is how
many 30 seconds to like 60 seconds or
something like that so it's it's almost
three times longer than anything else
you can imagine stuff just crumbles to
Flat at that point yeah and it happened
at four o'clock in the morning always so
that was always that was the challenge
too is that everybody's asleep in their
bed and you can imagine waking up in the
middle of the night and being
disoriented not knowing you know okay
what's going on the house is shaking
okay can you get out now I gotta get out
where do you go if you don't have a
light you know yeah so I mean it was
that's why it was so deadly you know and
I know that they've only put the death
toll maybe at you know 40 or 50 000 I
think is what they officially recorded
but
speaking of bodies when we were there
you know there were bodies literally
everywhere I mean the the stench was in
the air and so it wasn't and when you
know if people are telling you I've lost
80 people that I know personally like
family members friends and that's just
one person in the city of two million
who do the law of averages you're not
just 50 000 dead or probably in the
hundreds of thousands if not higher and
they only count you dead if they find
you yeah so there's probably a lot of
people in the bottom of the rubble and
they're not counting that because it's
not recovered yet how long ago did this
happen
uh this happened in I want to say it was
um
and all these disaster responses blend
together I think this was March March I
think it was March so about two months
no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I think this
was this was February whoa now now just
for those of you guys that are watching
um Brock's Ministry Gideon rescue
Brock's my brother by the way if you
didn't know that
um he's been on our show before but
um I'm so fascinated with your ministry
because you you you have all these
people that you work with spread out all
over the U.S pretty much and when you
band together and go over to these
disasters you're over there relatively
quick like you're able to form together
so from the time that the earthquake
happened to the time that you went over
there how what how close were you to the
beginning of that I think the earthquake
happened on a um on a Sunday morning
might end Monday morning and we were in
route by Thursday so I mean that's
pretty fresh there was a few days there
was a few days laps there we could have
been quicker on pulling the trigger but
one of the one of the things that
actually held us back was for the first
time we've actually had these search and
rescue dogs which are such a blessing
these are dogs they're like fifty
thousand dollars that God gifted to our
team we have we had three of them
available for this particular response
and so we had two handlers three dogs
and we knew that the dogs were gonna if
we could give anything you know over
there and help terms of help the dogs
would be the most needed
um just because these dogs are
incredible I mean they can smell human
beings whether you're dead or alive
you know they know the difference
whether you did earlier okay yeah when
they're trained there's different
trainings these dogs are actually
trained for cadaver and live find
um which made it a little more
challenging because there was so much
death so it was hard for the dogs to
distinguish you know but at the same
time I think God's hand was over the
trip and they were able to really you
know pinpoint
um in different locations you know
people that we were looking for and our
hammers had some incredible testimonies
of seeing people being pulled out of the
rubble just because the dogs were like
it's right here do they I know they have
good hearing do they hear stuff too it's
not so much hearing it's really the
their olfactory capability I mean you
know uh human beings we've got way more
taste buds they have like four you know
so it's like that's like yeah that's
right don't taste it but when it comes
to smell like like they knock us out of
the park every time like they say if you
put a cake like in the in a football
field you know they can smell not just
the cake they can smell every ingredient
in there for 100 yards right you know so
they can distinguish the flower the
sugar the baking soda this man if you
could teach your dog to cook
so they can smell cocaine in the cake so
they can smell the cocaine in the cake
and distinguish it and what's amazing
too is that these dogs also know how to
mentally check off when you're asking
them to search it it's just a game to
them it's not I don't know how much
capacity they have for for knowing like
I'm in a disaster zone I'm looking for
people that are trapped but to them it's
a game when you say search the way that
they're trained is they're mentally
checking off with all the smells okay I
see Mikey I see Scott I see Brock I see
Keith but I don't see this other anomaly
smell that's not here and so that's what
they're going after is they're trying to
find that one smell that's not there of
course in a disaster you have thousands
of people that are missing
mostly Labs okay yeah mostly labs they
do have some other like Belgian Malinois
and some other like hybrid you know
German Shepherds and other things they
use as well and you can use other breeds
too they have some golden retrievers but
labs are just that high energy High
Drive they're constantly wanting to
perform so it was amazing we got to the
airport this is the first time we've
ever taken these dogs over sees
internationally that was kind of a big
question we had was like how are they
going to do when we do our trips there's
not a lot of planning and it's not that
we don't believe in planning it's just
we don't have a lot of time so like
we're running off of a two-day heads up
you know in a lot of this and so we got
to the airport and we literally just
walked in there in faith saying we don't
know how they're going to get these dogs
on the plane but we just believe God's
Gonna open the doors and as soon as we
walked in there yeah because you can't
just walk a dog onto the plane yeah
that's a complicated thing actually yeah
it is especially internationally yeah so
when we walked with ticket agent you
know they were like oh okay well do you
have crates can we put them below the
plane and and I didn't think about that
part yeah we did well we didn't think
about but also one of our handlers she's
like really like she doesn't do that you
know so she was like I'm not putting my
dogs on the plane so they said okay
let's talk to supervisors they call
supervisor and they come back and you
know a few minutes live and say this is
amazing we've never seen it work out so
easily but you guys are allowed to take
your dogs on the plane you know that
wasn't because they knew what you were
doing or partly yeah I mean you know
that's a big part of how the doors open
up right when people are in need all
that bureaucratic red tape that keeps us
from things disappears you know and so
it's it's pretty incredible
um and uh you know
um you know I have a short little video
here these guys the in the plane these
dogs were like literally rock stars you
know like yeah let's take a picture
we're in the back of the plane the
stewardess literally have them in the
galley like the food Galley which is
probably not like super clean you know
yeah right and uh they're patting them
they're taking pictures of them they're
like pulling steak out of the out of the
you know the food and giving them like
little morsels of steak and treats and
whatever and the dogs were just loving
it you know and and it was pretty
incredible we didn't actually our
hammers didn't
um they were really worried about them
going to the bathroom you know on the
plane you know it's like 12 it's a 12
hour flight from so the dogs are in the
plane yeah yeah they're in the plane
just riding in the back like everybody
else like a passenger in a seat what do
you do take them in the bathroom sit on
the seats no they they uh held them back
from eating like food the day before so
like you know oh yeah and then they also
limited their fluid intake just to
dehydrate them a little bit but man it
was a miracle 12 hours not a single
accident wow and as soon as we landed
and got in the airport in Istanbul they
just like went all over the floor yeah
uh in the airport again in the airport
and then the airport they were like no
don't worry about it we'll clean it up
no big deal you know because I know
you're there to help you know they were
they were excited so it was you know put
baggage yeah
clean up and back
um so you know it's really amazing you
know on the flight over there it's
always incredible to us how we see how
God just orchestrates these Divine
appointments you know and uh of course
we have the dogs it's a big magnet and
this guy walks up to us he's on the
right there with the beard
um and his name is octai and he's
actually from Turkey
and he's flying back to like help his
family he's trying to look for his
mother-in-law who's missing oh wow and
he sees the dogs he sees our team and he
says man can you guys help me and we're
like well yeah sure like and he says
okay I know exactly where to go the
neighborhood the place he's like if you
guys can help me look and and it was
just an incredible don't really prayed
with him right there and uh you know
he's from a total Muslim culture like I
was going to ask how the religious yeah
yeah you know Turkey is a very um it's a
very Muslim country it's maybe more
modern in a lot of ways because it's a
part of the European Union but um and
there's a lot of secularism in the
country but if you're gonna default if
you're gonna default into the Muslim
culture and that thinking it's
interesting because historically that's
where the seven churches yeah they're
all in Turkey really yeah yeah and
what's incredible is that is that where
we were headed is the ancient state of
Antioch the first place in the Bible in
which we have the the term Christian
people call Christians was in was in
hetai in Antioch so that's where his
mother in law is from so here we are out
of all those 10 cities that are
devastated God is sending us to the
ancient city of Antioch and it's just
neat like all of a sudden all of these
details start falling into place and and
you know OCTA is like I got this like
you know I got contacts I got the place
where we're gonna stay like don't worry
about it like we'll hook it up so he
approached you just out of the blue like
what are you guys doing wow we even on
that flight we even had a medical
emergency where some poor guy was
dehydrated we had to like resuscitate
him give him fluid and like start an IV
and everything which even gave us
greater favor with the airlines because
they were like oh like you guys helped
us thank you so much like we wouldn't
have known what to do without you guys
yeah because if you're over the ocean
it's like you're 50 there yeah what are
you gonna do turn around you can't just
turn around I mean if you have a medical
problem in the middle of the ocean
that's a problem yeah it was it was a
big deal and it was funny because we
were trying to search throughout their
whole kit you know because they have a
whole doctor's kit with like medication
but they're all in Turkish oh you can't
read them you know it was like well you
know I think that's fluid it looks like
yeah yeah it's clear you drink it first
Google translate it's amazing we use it
a lot so when you fly over there you
don't have like an Airbnb or something
like you don't know where you're going
stay no idea they don't even have a plan
which is beautiful because God has
opened up these doors all the time and
he you get a chance to see how God works
amen yeah I mean literally we just know
that we're getting on a plane and we
don't even know if we're getting the
dogs on the plane right step one and
then as the dogs are on the plane then
you know like hey God's opening doors we
must be sending us you know and then
it's like Divine appointment Divine
appointment Divine appointment like you
know like you're in the right path
because you're just meeting all these
people so that's awesome that's a
picture of us working on the guy in the
plane
um you know giving him some fluid and
resuscitating him so it was it was
awesome it was a great way to start the
trip and again more pictures they're so
excited as soon as we landed in the
airport they said hey
where do you guys need to go and we're
like well we're trying to get to Antioch
and they're like okay follow us we're
going to take you to the the manager's
office in you know Istanbul so they they
whisk us through security whisk us
through all these things get us through
and they literally put us on flights out
of Istanbul directly to Adana which was
close
to you know maybe a few hours four or
five hour drive from from a tie but
better than 16. that was as close as
they could get that was as close again
because the airport was closed and well
yeah because you think if everything is
destroyed how do you even get into the
middle of the thing yeah that's a
problem yeah it is a problem
logistically all these things are from
the disasters are big giant puzzle yeah
just trying to plug in pieces and make
it work you know
um and so it was a blessing so and what
was amazing was that um here we are
landing in Adana when we got on this
flight into Donna this was really a
testimony to this to the Muslim mindset
of hospitality and Grace because when we
got on the plane from Istanbul to Adana
they actually had to ask over the
intercom they said are any of the
passengers going into this affected area
are they willing to give up their seats
for this search and rescue team and the
dogs
and it wasn't a demand it was a request
it was like are you willing to give
their seats and and you got to think
about it like all these people are going
into effective Zone to find family to
find friends to try to help or you know
what I mean and it's it's a real
emotional and trying time and
they all gave up seats so that we had a
we had a spot on the flight I mean it
was amazing it was humbling it was like
wow I mean you know Middle Eastern
hospitality is second to none and I
think that's what gets lost like
unfortunately like you know in in our
world especially in the western world is
that we get so pumped full of hate and
vitriol against you know the Muslim
culture that you don't realize that man
there's a lot of beautiful cultures and
people out there that are not what is
portrayed in Hollywood or in the movies
you know they're not all suicide and I
think that works yeah I think that works
on both sides of the events too because
their view of us is that we're just
these infidels and all we care about is
our you know bling bling money and this
and that and here's a group of people
that are spending their own money their
own time coming over to help them in
their time of need I think that's
actually neat yeah in fact that that
actually was mentioned to us when we
were there they said they said
specifically that
um if you were born in the United States
automatically you are a Christian in
their mindset so in the Turkish mindset
like you were born there are terrorists
yeah
but a certain kind of Christian yeah a
Christian that eats pork and smokes and
cusses and watches movies and watches
whatever what kind of Christians do that
a lot different shows different show
yeah yeah but no it's true like the
media the media that we have here really
negatively impacts our image around the
world yeah and and this is all they see
you're exactly right like what they look
at us they look like now these guys are
from Hollywood the same they're not
they're not faithful to their spouses
they're not you know it's like it
negatively impacts our view around the
world too yeah absolutely yeah I think
the majority of people either think
Christians are mega church or Catholic
yeah one of those two yeah and that's
that's been the case for a long time
because you know like whenever they're
thinking about whenever there's war like
in the US between another country well
they're automatically you know evil I
mean you think about like World War One
World War II right
propaganda machine goes to work that's
right yeah the dirty comments and it's
the leadership it's not the people and I
think unfortunately you know that the
false you know idea about Grace within
Christianity has done a lot of damage
around the world because people view
Christians as very loose when it comes
to morals because they're just like ah
well God's going to cover it you know
God's going to forgive me and it's like
but there's accountability like there's
greater accountability some of these
other cultures than there is even in our
own culture yeah and uh so yeah it's an
interesting cultural exchange you know
between the two groups
um so here we are Atlanta to Donna
um there's teens from all over the world
it's amazing we get to see you know all
these different groups and that's what's
really neat too about disasters is it
really brings together International
communities and so you get to meet
cultures that you've never met before a
team from Serbia and there was a there's
a whole Danish team there and there was
a you know team from Saudi Arabia and so
you know just kind of a neat neat way to
interact and uh
okay so this is what this is what they
flew on to get there right yeah and so
as we landed here I remember they gave
us a form it was from the United Nations
and the Forum said please list your team
your capabilities what you can do so I
filled on there I said I said yeah we
got some dogs and we got some medical
skills and then that was it like we
didn't really have anything else so you
know we're not like amazing beyond that
and and then there was one little
section any other skills you have is
like you know the other box and I
checked it and I said we have prayer
and I submitted it to the United Nations
and they were you know the guys that
were taking it there I don't know if
they ever saw it but but you know really
that's that's honestly how this these
these trips are even successful a
because we have no idea what we're doing
you know like we literally are just
stepping on a plane with faith that
God's gonna get us there that he's got a
mission he's got a plan and we think
oftentimes so small and God wants to
think you know Universal scale yeah and
so um a lot of it is bathed in prayer
and so as we landed here we recognized
that man like we we need to be praying
like Lord what's the next step how are
you going to get us to Antioch you know
from Madonna do you want us to drive you
know and that's a four or five hour long
drive Journey you know all the way there
traffic blocked and you know trying to
get in there or do you have a more
direct route and can you even just rent
a car I mean and being on some of these
trips before I've always kind of seen
how God has just always had he has the
direct route right like God doesn't
waste time like when he needs the
mission completed he's going to send the
right tool you know like if if Elijah
needs to be taken to Heaven he sends a
fire chair Philip needs to be
transported it's like it's done you know
and so um there is a sense of urgency
and so I was looking at the airport and
I was I told Dylan I said Dylan I said
as we're walking out on the tarmac here
I was like hey there's got to be
helicopters somewhere around here right
like that'd be the most direct route in
human speaking and so we literally
walked around saw these big planes there
was no helicopters until way across the
tarmac on the other side there was a
little Coast Guard Station like a turkey
Coast Guard Station so we literally show
up at this turkey Coast Guard Station
and had gotten a ride over the little
airport security guy you know like I
mean that's pretty amazing in itself
that you even got a chance to go over
there like I don't think I've done Lots
of airports I don't think I could walk
over and naturally be like I want to go
to that building over there and have
somebody take me to the building you
know
you know it's a it's a combination of
just being bold and not knowing what
you're doing and walking into the office
the security office and saying hey
through Google translate we need we need
to go over here
and the other teams are like doing their
own
trying to find your own way yeah the
other teams are all there trying to
arrange rides and they're trying to rent
cars like we had heard that you couldn't
even rent a car because everybody's
there trying to rent a car so like
Transportation was a big problem and we
walked over there and the security guy
he was funny he was like yeah just give
me give me a minute he did a few little
duties got his little car we hopped in
the car we drove across the tarmac and
um and I'll never forget man it was just
kind of a surreal moment here we are in
the car actually driving driving across
and here we are pulling up to helicopter
base you know and it's like I only have
one helicopter they got like six
helicopters all up front and so it's
like hey like we're in a good spot right
yeah
if we need a ride it's just all it is is
asking somebody for a ride you know are
you kidding me and so we walked in and
we met the commander and we explained
our situation the commander and he said
he said yeah he said I think we can help
you out hold on you know you know this
is this is like this is like the guy
that goes in and asked the king for
something right and and he asks for the
kingdom keys to the kingdom and they
think it's like you can't do that you
can't do that it's like the answer is
always no until you ask yeah look at
that well you know a principle that
we've really been able to put into
practice in our ministry is is you know
from Joshua's experience like I'll give
you everywhere where you place the soul
of your foot wow so literally like if we
have that boldness to know that God's
with us then man place your feet boldly
plant them boldly say hey I need this
and chances are God's gonna work on that
person's heart and be like you know what
you're right like how can I help you
because God wants to save people yeah
he's in the business of saving people so
this is definitely in line with what he
wants yeah so we're talking to these
guys interacting these guys sharing with
these guys we gave him patches they give
us patches you know we're getting some
glow tracks you know like you know the
whole thing you know it's like and this
isn't a country we're not supposed to be
able to share literature because these
are these are Muslims yeah they're
Muslims and no that's a government
Muslims right so if you're going to get
in trouble it's probably with these guys
yeah but yeah see a common Bond like
they they naturally ask questions yeah
because they're like well yeah how did
you get here and you know who are you
and what are you doing and what is this
about and so you get a chance to share
like genuinely like hey like our God is
amazing and he brought us here you know
I think it's I think it's why Jesus
chose the main method of his ministry
really to help people heal with them
because it breaks down all cultural
lines literally any any sort of of I
don't know what you call it racism for
lack of a better term in that day that's
what this is really is and and you're
helping somebody it's like think about
that that dissipates all natural
resistance because you're this person
from this other country yeah yeah yeah
absolutely and that's that's what's
amazing about a disaster is that it
spares no culture it spares no religion
yeah right so it doesn't matter whether
it's North Korea or whether it's
Southern California I would love to go
to North Korea you know there's ever a
disaster I'm on the plane with you okay
I'll hold you to it
so here we are in the you know talking
they have this nice awesome police
helicopters the commander that we're
talking with here Dylan and I Dylan's
one of the guys that was on the trip
with us and uh and then and then what
was funny is that they actually they
actually passed us off and we didn't
know this like they said yeah sure give
us till like a noon I think is what they
told us noon we'll we'll have a
helicopter ready we'll pick you up and
then I get a call on my cell phone
because I'd given him my number I got to
call my cell phone and it's like hello
my name is John Smith and I'm with the
United States Air Command for you know
the the Turkish Mission here and I heard
that you need air support I was like
whoa well I was like I was like well we
were actually talking to the Turkish
guys and they were going to Pride Hill
he's like well I think they passed you
off to me and I said sure okay and he
said what do you need and I said well I
said this is our team this is how many
people we have so many dogs we have he
said done he said I'm sending you air
you know the helicopters you need right
now and so literally from America yeah
yeah Air Force you know this is the US
Army
so what shows up in this video as you
see is that here we are riding and uh um
you know when we look out the window
here in a second you're gonna see like
they sent us literally the Blackhawks
right you know like the US Army
Blackhawks that have landed two of them
not just one two of them for us to load
our entire team on I mean it was
honestly I just want to ride in the
thing yeah it's amazing why is the
military not doing this yeah they're
just like we'll give you a ride
the logistics here's the crazy thing
about it is that those dogs are such
special assets right like that doesn't
come doesn't just show up I mean when
you show up with dogs no matter how much
money you have there's time it takes a
train time and everything you know yeah
so people realize these dogs are very
valuable assets so that was our calling
card in a lot of ways you know with with
the military here and these guys are
awesome I mean they're our own United
States military they load us on the
helicopters about an hour and some
change flight across the the bait that's
cool I mean I think they're burning
thousand dollars a minute right oh yeah
yeah but it's like how much is a life
worth yeah but I mean like it's
impressive that they would do something
like that that's that's cool and it's
and and I mean the thing I think is
really cool is it's like what it's kind
of like what's in it for them yeah you
know yeah yeah I mean yeah maybe
turkey's in Ally maybe it puts them in
good graces governmental wise but we're
a much bigger militarily and yeah
economically and all that than they are
so
yeah and you know you know to the credit
of our you know just that spirit that we
have in the United States like I think
most U.S citizens and even our military
desires to really help when it counts
you know what I mean like like I think
at the heart of what people want to do
is they want to help when they can and
so I mean these guys I mean they
probably see some pretty awful tourism
pretty awful situations so to actually
be on the side of doing something that's
good and valuable saving life is that
taking life I mean like I think that's
attractive and you know the Bible says
every good gift comes down from above
and that's what's in that's what's
amazing is that in in in a crisis or
disaster moment it doesn't matter if
we've had beef for 20 years with each
other you know like if I see your family
hurt or I see you hurting whatever the
natural tendency and I think God has
designed us as human beings is to have
compassion no you know now obviously in
Good Samaritan you know there's some
that just would pass on by but there are
those that would stop and render Aid and
say hey
this is a this is a situation at the
risk to my own safety I'm gonna help
this guy
and so it's a Biblical you know I I have
a guy that goes to my church and and
he's always sharing stories of the
emergency room um he's a a nurse
anesthetist and uh he worked in a unit
where you know they would have guys that
that would shoot at the cops and stuff
and then they would get shot out or
whatever like then they'd come into the
hospital and they would have to work on
them like you would work on the police
officer and and their their first and
foremost like thing to do is to save
that life right there and you know
that's amazing that that we do have that
instilled inside of us like yeah I think
it's a protection in this evil world
where life is so cheap and it is
extinguished that God has given Humanity
just that compassion you know to like
hey when someone's hurting like it's
hard to turn it's hard to turn a blind
eye and and people that aren't like that
everybody kind of recognize like yeah
there's something broken in that
person's right line like they're not
normal to just like kill people with no
thought No Remorse nothing sociopath
everybody recognizes like that's just
wrong right yeah absolutely
so it was amazing flight uh and what was
neat is you know I had this picture here
was neat is that octai right remember
octa's with us right so wait this guy's
just like I picked the ride
he literally he's literally trying to
bug me the whole time as we're loading
on the hook on he's like dude I gotta
talk to you like how do you know these
people and I'm like I can't explain this
right now just get on the helicopter
yeah I don't know any of these people
but I know the guy that knows these
people you know so it's like literally
this is this is the witnesses so from
his Muslim mindset all of a sudden this
whole Paradigm is beginning to shift
where he's saying whoa like who are
these people that claim to know God
that's amazing and that that when they
ask God answers wow right I mean what
does that do like for anybody who's
seeking religion I think that's the
biggest thing that we want to know as
human beings does it work yeah like if
you claim in that Buddhism really works
yeah does it work do you reach nirvana
like do you have some connection that
nobody else has that yeah that puts you
in a state of mind that you can flow
through this awful life in in a better
way than I am yeah like that's the
natural inquisitive and so it's so
amazing OCTA gets to see like firsthand
like wow like this God that they're
talking about is alive yeah Buddha can't
get you a Blackhawk helicopter no but
God can no no it'd be a great t-shirt
so here we are the land at us after the
flight landed Us in this field just this
big open field like we had no idea where
we were and yeah good luck guys see ya
just like dropped us off and now it was
the next step was like okay well what do
we do and again like prayer you know
like that's that's the way we start
everything it's like all right Lord keep
their phone numbers
that's not even the thought that I
thought about like that's a little scary
getting dropped off in a location that's
that's not easy to just go okay I'm done
I need to go home now yeah right and it
but it is awesome because
um that whole crew not only you know we
couldn't speak to him because it's so
loud we didn't have we weren't plugged
in the same comms but we had glow tracks
so do the whole crew got you know glowed
up you know so they got to know like hey
these guys are definitely different you
know leaving it in the Blackhawk
helicopter you know the soldier just
sitting there waiting going away what's
this yeah wow so it was you know it's a
blessing every everywhere you go there's
opportunities right because because at
the end of the day
God cares not only for the people of
turkey but he cares about those guys
flying that blackout amen yeah he's
working on everyone yeah everyone like
it's like the mission is universal not
the Coast Guard guys at the turkey
station right everyone he's working he's
working on your faith yeah I mean I I
don't know how many times I sat and I've
listened to these stories and my mouth
is always like wide open like every time
but he's just like yeah of course we did
this you know what are you kids
yeah so so we tried we got it we're kind
of by this highway we jumped up on this
highway and there's just like trucks and
cars and everything passing along and
we're trying to flag down some sort of
vehicle to like get into you know octai
knows exactly where that neighborhood is
but we gotta at least get to it now so
we have no Transportation it's a
religious hitching all right yeah
literally just hitching a ride trying to
find a truck or somebody that was
something couldn't get anybody to stop
everybody's just blowing by us you know
just not even interested and and then
one of our guys flagged down an
ambulance and uh we packed all of us in
this ambulance
um and what was awesome about it was
that I hadn't thought about that
actually the perfect vehicle for getting
into a disaster Zone would be an
ambulance an ambulance right you know
like and the most direct drive yeah the
most direct route so and the reason is
because you've got the little and the
little lights can people get off the
road so you guys are flagging a truck
and God's like no no I got something
better
pass yeah so here so here we are on this
image and I think this is the um lights
and sirens
straight through the checkpoints yeah it
lights and sound straight to the
checkpoint and uh you know it's funny
because um I don't think I've ever
packed as many people dogs people
everybody inside this ambulance and
unfortunately some of our team members
got real sick you know yeah with no
windows in that thing I would be the one
hanging my head out the back door yeah
um but you know God was good and I don't
think we could have been prepared for
what we saw once we landed on the ground
it Ground Zero now this is Ground Zero
this is like the destruction and what
I'm about to show you guys is like
literally something out of a movie
um you know the destruction is just it's
unfathomable I mean like where do you
start you know it's like wow the rubble
is is is everywhere you know what you
know you know what he chained off yeah
you know none of these places have been
searched in the way that they should be
searched for people and it's just the
hopelessness that's just on the street
and with the citizens and the people
there it's it's desperate oh it's not
like there's like probably not like
bulldozers and stuff in abundance to
remove wreckage right yeah so every
every piece of equipment
s like top
priority you know used by those that
have money or influence or yes I mean it
becomes a real desperate situation and
this is literally what we walked into
when we were dropped off by the
ambulance was just a war zone you know I
mean it literally looked like somebody
bombed the city and you know this is
this is where we're at now this is where
we're operating I cannot imagine what
that was like seconds after that thing
happened
um what they had to have something
because it seems like there's at least a
path and you wouldn't expect the rubble
to just like
the days before we got there I'm sure
one of their pieces of work was just to
clear streets as much as they could a
couple days I mean had two two or three
days after the event so it was really
neat right away we were able to get our
dogs working there were there were
groups and as soon as we see you know as
soon as those groups see dogs walking to
the streets it was really hard because
where we got dropped off was probably a
quarter mile hike to where this
apartment building was where octa's
mother-in-law was you know buried
probably and and that was just really
tough because every time you'd walk by
somebody they would be like please like
you have a dog like please like will you
search my will you search this building
I know my family's in here and he knows
exactly where to go even though it looks
like Devastation because yeah I drove up
to uh well I was in I was in Red Bluff
you know last weekend and I drove down
to paradise and I went to the look for
the place that I used to live
if I had not known the address I
wouldn't know where I was right crazy
totally it was like crazy totally
different yeah wow so I that can be a
difficult thing like even if you're
familiar with the area like I knew where
I live but no I had no reference this is
still like all demolished or are they
building back up or they're building
back up but there's still whole sections
where it's just like totally burnt down
totally wiped out like three there's
three quarters of the of the town is
driveway cement pad nothing on it weeds
so it's like you see all these driveways
around and they've cleared everything
but it's just like subdivisions of
driveways I can only imagine like you're
there and it's like you think you know
where you're at because the streets but
yeah it looks different and OCTA had a
truck he had trouble with that he had
you know he was disoriented and like man
I I think I know I'm on the street but I
don't know it's like it's so different
and it's so changed like I can't tell
you that this is right so it took us a
while but once we got there the dogs got
right to work and you know it's a real
blessing you know to be able to see
these guys work so how long before a dog
found somebody
uh it was that first day that when we
were already locating like hours yeah we
were already locating people as soon as
we were on the ground
um and and the nice thing about the dogs
is that they're really mobile so like
they can and it's just an indication
right like the dog can't tell you yeah
positively there's somebody here but
what they can do is they can alert and
they can say yes I smell a human here
and that gives the crews hope and a
sense of direction say hey we're going
to keep digging on this side so
like how dangerous is that to follow a
dog like a dog finds a spot like how
dangerous is it to get into some of
these spots like do you you probably
don't even know that it's going to hold
up so this is probably one of the more
dangerous things I've ever done in my
life because because you're exactly
right is that everything everything has
so changed you know like from an
engineering standpoint nothing's safe
yeah right like no engineer would look
at that situation and say I think you
could be in there safely for a couple
hours and nothing would happen you start
clearing Rubble yeah you don't know what
like little stick it's holding it up and
I'm seeing glass and wires Live Wire
yeah yep it's it's a it's a dangerous
spot and and then we had aftershocks too
so that was the other so it's still you
would be in there and then the Earth
would start moving and these buildings
are still shifting and so I mean it was
it was a dynamic situation the dogs of
course add some layer of protection
because you can send a dog into a
smaller space that you having to go in
there spend that time in there so speak
to that for just a second because did
you guys talk about this when you were
there with your team like hey look we're
putting our lives at risk if you go into
this building there is a chance you will
not come out like yeah we had that talk
wow we had to talk and actually it was
prompting one of our teamers was there
he actually it was it was great I'm glad
he did he led the charge he actually
called his wife and said I'm gonna have
this conversation with my wife first I
suggest you guys probably do this and
they talked about it as a couple and his
wife totally was like man if there's
somebody alive in there I'd say go for
it you know and so they agreed as a
couple to say this is worth the risk for
us as a family and he had kids you know
and so the same thing for all of us like
I called my wife and we had the
conversation and you know we were agreed
that this is this is worth the risk if I
mean praise God that you have this is
why God honors this kind of stuff is
because you think about the gift that
you're giving to those people
it's like you've already made the choice
of life and death right there yeah even
if nothing happens you've already made
that chat that that choice yeah well and
and I think on a larger scale I think we
have to realize like if if we believe
and we have this hope you know in Christ
eternally
then who's at the greater risk for
somebody without Christ somebody doesn't
know so if I'm secure then it doesn't
matter what happens to me right I mean
like if the building I mean would it be
awful for my family and and you know
having to pick up the pieces and yeah
yeah but but at the same time like
what's the chances of reaching someone
who doesn't know wow you know so it's
you know really reminding me of what it
says in John 15 this is verse 13 greater
love has no man than this then delay
ones down his life for his friends
and then he says you are my friends if
you do whatever I command you
yeah yeah and that's that's it you know
in the gospel commission it's amazing
about that the gospel commission if you
think about it like there are no enemies
in God's mind yeah like everybody is
open field for being his friend I I mean
you know I think it's so beautiful that
you're over there doing this I mean I
try to try to think of this on the
reverse side I mean you know with with
the Muslim faith send people over here
if we had a big disaster
I don't know I mean I mean that's a
that's a fascinating thing to think of
the Dynamics of that on the other way
around I can only imagine what those
Muslims observing you going and digging
in that building must have thought I
think this
only works in Christianity because I
don't think only God can put that
you know only God can change the heart
to where a person is willing to do that
right like it's not just any religion or
any faith or any view of God
it's God tremends forming a person's
heart to be like his to have that Heart
of Love That would do that so
maybe some would yeah
I mean sure I mean the Bible says it
says for for some maybe it may be a good
man some would die right yeah but what
about for your enemy
that's impossible without God
yeah
yeah and and you're exactly right I
think in all of the religious systems
this concept fails or falls short
no because all of the systems are not
built upon
the exchanging of one's life for another
but upon the preservation of your own
self yeah and and you know
at the risk you know Christianity stands
at the risk of sounding arrogant in in
that respect but really it's to say yeah
there's a whole lot of Christians
aren't necessarily transformed right
it's only that transformed heart it's
only some somebody that's completely
transformed by Jesus that can do that
and that's where each one of us have to
to have that intimate walk otherwise
we're not that person right and that's
where God is trying to bring us to is to
become that person yeah yeah naturally
you know it's a fight you know like I
know in my mind personally you know it's
a fight because I'll be honest like I
don't want to die
I don't have a death wish to die but in
the bigger context of the great
controversy which we're facing between
Good and Evil
like I've been so blessed like I've I
have seen the hand of God I've seen his
goodness I've seen his character I know
who he is and if his choice was to lay
me to rest I would totally trust him
that he knows better than what I think
and in the end it's going to work out
even better than I would have ever
imagined and and what an amazing thought
to die doing something that you know is
super honorable or whatever you know
what I mean like to me I would feel good
if if I woke up on the on the you know
Resurrection Day and and to look back
and even though I missed out on you know
my kids getting married and whatever
like that I think that just simple
thought of like I died serving God you
know yeah I think it would be a happy
thought yeah yeah I mean it's all God's
character right I think being in a death
like that's almost like martyrdom you
know that's that's a living witness in
itself like I'm always thinking of the
story of the Rachel jig that was shot at
Columbine you know there was more people
watching her funeral than Princess Diana
this is a girl at Columbine Colorado
that nobody knew right but right when
she died for her faith now the whole
nation knows who she is and and there
was friends of hers that watched her
along the way saw her struggles saw her
um boldness she went from struggling to
being very bold before she died and then
everybody was like whoa she really was
like what a true Christian should be so
I think you know and in her death she
made more of an impact because
it turned in her life turned into this
uh her dad continued to go school to
school and do this Rachel's Challenge
thing I mean yeah some some teenage girl
in Colorado is now known Nationwide in
schools in this program and uh you know
when she was alive she told her dad she
said one day I'm going to be on Oprah
and sure enough when her dad got invited
on Oprah he turned around and saw a big
picture of his daughter and he just
broke down and every person in the
audience was just crying they had to
shut down the cameras and stuff and it's
just like
she probably maybe would have never been
on Oprah if she would have just lived
out her life yeah but because of how
impactful that death was you know yeah
so just just trying to add to what
you're saying you know like absolutely
if you were to die over there what if
that saved one two three four people's
salvation well and God works in the
process of multiplication right you know
because nothing is ever wasted in God's
plan yeah so you know you think of all
the great men in history who have given
their lives for the gospel cause
and I wouldn't say a single one of them
was a waste no you know they they gave
something infinitely you know like it
was Tyndale that's you know prayed Lord
Open the Eyes of the king of England you
know and now Stephen getting stoned and
now we have the King James Bible you
know the world over it's just like wow
what a gift you know what I mean how
many lives have been impacted because
that man gave his life and prayed that
prayer for his enemies wow right like
the King was the one that was killing
him and he was like Lord just like
Stephen prayed he prayed the same
prayers like Father forgive them for
they know not what they do as they're
throwing rocks at his head I mean it's
really truly amazing yeah it's the same
prayer that Jesus prayed so going back
to Keith's Point like the only way that
this is even possible is if you if you
actually are connected with that God of
love and you allow that same love to
transform your life no and then others
get to see that and they get to have
that same transformation if they choose
so that's the power so the on the flip
side of that though
you know what has God called us to do
for some it is to risk their physical
life in a very real way
but for others
you know like Paul says
I Die daily right
right and what are you supposed to do
being buried and brought to life again
Jesus has a mission you know he says in
Luke 19 10 for the son of man has come
to seek and save that which was lost
yeah
yeah so you don't you don't have to put
yourself right in a physically dangerous
situation that's certainly one component
and one way to do it but there are
multiple ways that can be done to seek
and save those that are lost and when
you align your will with the will of God
that's the will of God so going into a
random bunch of pieces of rubble seeking
and saving that which is lost is like
that's in God's wheelhouse that's what
he wants to do it starts with
surrendering like you said though your
will to God's like what is God's will
for your life that's what you need to
follow well on this and you know we say
this all the time
each of us Witnesses disasters daily
right I mean it could be the loss of a
loved one it could be a financial crisis
it could be a medical you know problem
that somebody's struggling with like
there are there are disasters around us
all the time like it doesn't have to be
large-scale turkey you know with
thousands of people dead or dying I mean
just look around I mean you know the
homeless guy that we pass on the road
that's struggling just to figure out
what the you know true purpose of life
is you know so there's opportunities to
seek and say the loss on so many fronts
and that's what I love about God is that
God's people have an opportunity to
really be involved in this work the
world over and and if there are true
committed Christians you would see an
incredible opportunity before us in
reaching people that man do they just
need hope yeah you know giving them hope
did you hear any stories of anything
Supernatural happening no I'm glad you
asked that question about you yeah
because I remember hearing you say
something I don't know if we ever did it
on camera though no so this this is so
this isn't amazing right and and this
this proves this proves our point that
God actually doesn't even need us yeah
right like like take the human factor
out of it God doesn't need Humanity if
he chooses to use a thousand different
ways yeah and they have this little boy
that they pulled out the rub we didn't
pull them out but it was very close we
heard all the stories around us
and this little boy was pulled out of
the rubble and he had been like
it was a while five days maybe
underneath the rebel five or six days
now physiologically speaking two days
without water you're in trouble yeah
yeah so five days double the time you're
really in trouble especially as a kid
you know
um and so the course the news crews were
like hey man like were you hungry or
thirsty or like how did that work you
know being trapped in the rubble for
five days and this little kid said oh no
he said every day he said a man in white
came and gave me a little food and a
little water
that's amazing yeah yeah I mean if you
think if you think of the the Angelic
presence that's there as well I mean
you're you're working side by side with
these angels that are also working on
the preservation of life right right and
the devil's trying to take life right
yeah so Devil's trying to like literally
it's like two people it's like this
Clash of light and darkness together
yeah you were you were in the middle of
a cosmic struggle between good and evil
life and death and it's amazing like
when God needs to step in he steps in it
deserve life you know probably didn't
have a way to do this but it would have
been interesting to like check his
levels yeah right seriously yeah
I mean just like have yeah and I'm not
doubting it at all it would have been an
interesting Testament to other people
right yeah just in case there aren't any
Skeptics out there that's exactly what
the Bible says two men in white apparel
came up why are you gazing like that's
how it always happened and men in white
apparel yeah what if he went like oh and
by the way I put the little white wafers
in my
yeah yeah you know but you know think
about this too from the from the Muslim
mindset a very dark country that that
does not know Jesus or the power of the
loving God right a loving God and look
how God is trying to reach this people
he's giving them evidence after evidence
after evidence after story after Story
preserving life where he can right the
dev wants to plunge them off the cliff
into darkness and God's saying no I have
people here who are precious that I'm
going to preserve and so it it it's you
know man you know it's such a crazy and
it is interesting the stories I hear of
people that convert because they
actually saw Jesus or something it's
Muslims they have a dream of Jesus I
wonder if it's just because they're you
know they're they're so close to the
truth you know they believe in God he's
our father they actually believe in
Jesus they believe Jesus is coming back
um I wonder if it's just that
you know there are no missionaries or
whatever and so God's like you know an
angel or I need to come talk to that
remind me of that point because as we
come to octai had some incredible
perspectives to share from the Muslim
perspective what he saw and the
difference with just Christianity and so
but it's amazing so here we are you can
see these buildings are absolutely
pancaked um there's just not and these
are like four-story buildings you know
now they're two stories or one and a
half you know
um and uh we came to this one site this
was one of the first sites we worked at
um and this was a significant site
because the the lady at this particular
house had lost like five children
including like her family members and
stuff and so like when she asked us to
help her of course how can you turn down
a plea to help somebody that's lost all
their children you know so we stayed
late into the night we had a backhoe it
was great we were using the dogs had
swept the area but they didn't seem to
really hit on anything specific
um and so we spent just a lot of time
working with this lady she was obviously
in just terrible grief you know losing
her family and you have to understand
the Muslim culture the body is
everything their belief is that if you
don't have the body the soul wanders in
hell until it can be reunited the body
so if you have a body that's
not anywhere which is interesting about
suicide bombing but if you don't have to
be able to collect that body like it's
it's everything so um
so we had uh of course a real burden to
just try to help this poor lady and so
here we are digging and the tools of
course that you have it's I mean like
look at that I mean like you have rebar
you know and like how do you even
untangle that rebar like we have a
jackhammer right and it's a pretty beefy
jacket but man it's it's painstaking
painstaking like digging through this
you're literally digging through
concrete with your hands and literally
one chip at a time trying to get through
you get enough space that you can get
the cutter in there you'd cut the rebar
you'd make the hole bigger I mean this
is literally how you would have to
search these buildings if you thought
that somebody was down below you know
buried in the rubble
um it was man yeah it was just it was it
was hopeless I mean like you literally
were up against just that feeling of
absolute hopelessness where it's like
God unless you help us find these people
like there's no there's no way
um so we stated we stated a camp we had
a you know our accommodations were
pretty rough but we stayed at this like
little tent city that they had they were
having some refugees stay here and we
stayed right right alongside with them
um just kind of you know pop up 10 tent
cities here and it was cold uh in that
particular uh season it was really cold
um I think we were even below freezing a
couple of the nights
um and it was neat though like this was
Sabbath morning Dylan he brought us
harmonica and here he is playing for us
uh some some awesome hymns and our team
is comprised of more than just you know
the Christians that we have we actually
have a lot of Muslims that are part of
what we're doing now too so it becomes
an incredible platform to just share the
faith and the hope that we have and the
beauty of the Sabbath and just because
it was Sabbath it didn't necessarily end
our work it just changed the focus of
how we ministered right instead of
instead of the focus being about oh we
got to dig with our hands for the rubble
it was like Lord how can we minister to
people and so it was just really awesome
how God
brought us to these really powerful
Ministry points throughout the day on
Sabbath where in fact we tried we tried
to do a little bit of digging we tried
to like get in there and jump in there
and it was funny every time we tried to
on Sabbath somebody else would step in
with a tool and be like no that's okay I
got this so like our team literally
literally got this whole different
experience where we were you know
resting and just ministering to people
who were hurting
um and this picture here
um I'll never forget this gentleman
we were in his house we had brought the
dogs he was so excited because nobody
was there helping him and we made a
sweep with the dogs they didn't find
anything and then all of a sudden
somebody came with a thermal camera and
we were looking with a thermal camera
and uh
um
and we didn't find anything with the
thermal camera and in this particular
house we're also was there was a family
in the next apartment over that were all
crushed and they were still visible that
you could actually see them they were
crushed in the in the other apartment
and
um and uh
he was looking for his parents who were
still missing and they were like in the
next apartment over and
um he couldn't hear him he couldn't see
him he couldn't you know get to him at
all and he kind of just as he realized
that the calvary had come and the
Cavalry was now probably leaving because
like you can only spend so much time
that's the challenge it's like you can't
spend three days in your whole trip
searching you know what I mean for one
person as much as you want to you have
to move on like maybe there's somebody
more viable maybe there's something
that's actually you know a little closer
to being saved
so our resources have to move on and I
remember him coming out and so our dog
teams had left and I just sat down next
to this guy and he spoke English he was
from Istanbul
and he just looked at me you know he's
just
just you know crying and he said
um
he said you know even if I don't ever
find my parents
he's like I have hope
he's like you know I have hope
he's like because you guys and so many
other teams have come from around the
world to help me in my hour of need he's
like it gives me hope
he was just like wow
so much I wanted to tell him you know
it's like I just want to like I hugged
him and like I gave him a glow track and
then he immediately opened up and he
just started reading this glow track and
I think it was like certainty and
uncertain times you know she just he's
just pouring over this wheelchair
because man he's he's hurting like he's
spiritually hemorrhaging right and he
needs a spiritual tourniquet and so a
man it was just like it was so so
heartbreaking but so heartwarming at the
same time it's just such a weird
dichotomy right like you know like wow
God's brought us here at this moment for
this guy at the same time man we can't
spend time here like we got to keep
moving so it's like you just commit him
into God's hand say Lord like be with
this guy you know and and bring him
bring him to a more beautiful
understanding of your character and who
you are
and um and that was just you know that
was Sabbath man all day Sabbath we were
just ministering different places this
guy in the middle here I think his name
is uh mofot or mofot mofots he was from
Turkey but he was living in Germany
again amazing guy he was like his own
family was missing and he was sticking
with us and helping us translate and
helping to work even though his own
family was still missing and he hadn't
been able to see where his family is at
so we eventually sent dogs over to his
neighborhood and unfortunately his
family was killed in the earthquake but
he's just unselfishly poured himself out
to it didn't matter what was going on
and that's what we saw a lot like one of
the guys that housed our team he went to
eight funerals wow in one day eight
funerals for his family wow and yet
still found time at the end of the day
to house our team to cook them a meal to
wash them to wash their feet like they
help them clean up and everything like
dude it was amazing you know and this
guy lost I mean I don't know in our
culture you'd be if you attended eight
of your family members funerals if you
would have the capacity to help a
stranger that was needing a place to
stay I would be sitting in the corner
just like you know how could you even
get up off the floor yeah these I mean
it's amazing this culture has such
incredible resilience and and just and I
think it's that it's that ancient
abrahamic Hospitality right wow like
Abraham was known for his hospitality
and praised the Lord like through his
lineage he's passed that down to these
guys and and that's what's so awesome
it's beautiful I think there's a lot
that we can learn from their culture in
that sense we ended up the last part
kind of of this whole story we ended up
in this building
on Sabbath afternoon
and this building was a six-story
building that was reduced to three so
three three stories that complex
collapse with the basement and we found
positive heat signatures in this
building
um and the dogs actually alerted on this
building too so not only the dogs alert
but as we were digging uh this building
uh we found that there was you know some
thermal imaging that actually showed us
um that there were people that were
alive and so immediately like the teams
sprang into action the locals were there
digging it was just you know amazing
feat they'd already pulled I think three
people out of this building live that
were just you know under one layer and
so here we are digging in this building
trying to help where we can and of
course the digging is painfully slow you
know like you're pulling out one piece
at a time you were using kitchen pots to
put Rubble in to then pass it up so
somebody gets out you know as we're
digging in this building and um you know
again a little bit of Jackhammer maybe a
little bit of water to cut down on the
dust and then it's just piece by piece
cutting the rebar and we realized really
quickly like our team was not set up for
this kind of rescue you know what I mean
like we're literally digging with our
hands and so our prayer request went up
to you know God please you got to send
us hands you got to send us help you got
to send us like another team's got more
equipment more experience more skill
whatever and it was awesome God actually
sent us
um God sent us the French and um this
guy we're actually listening here you
could actually hear tapping in the walls
you know like as you're listening with a
stethoscope you could hear somebody like
tapping like we would tap they would
respond like military French yeah no
this is this is a Turkish military Air
Force guy I think okay um but I think of
this next picture here here's the
thermal imaging we have some thermal
imaging here and the heat signage you
can see that that kind of the red uh is
actually real real distinct heat
signatures of bodies of course
everybody's real excited that we we
found these bodies you know huddled in
this cavity or wherever it was you know
um now is that just an app on a phone no
this is military-grade thermal imaging
the guy that's holding the machine is
actually above it has a kind of wand
sticking out up above he's kind of
holding the handheld and it's you know
it's a probably a sixty thousand dollar
unit you know that they can actually
look through concrete and walls and wow
and see heat signatures from human
beings they can see the other small but
it was awesome here comes the French
right and it was really neat to have
that support because these guys are like
the best of the best the European Union
could offer you know the full
firefighter Squad with all their
equipment and all their you know
leadership and man these guys are like
military Precision like they had they
had a whole and it was beautiful because
we had been working hard like we've been
working like this was 36 hours straight
of us digging in this building being
awake trying to help these people and
what is this like this is a ground
sensing sonar so they set up the ground
sensing sonar to try to see if they can
get some other images as well and then
and so they had some positive feedback
as well and so just of course nothing's
guaranteed but all the indications are
there that there's somebody buried alive
you know in this building and uh and the
French were they were an incredible
asset to the to the efforts
um they and and
and it was great because it gave our
team a rest like we were just full on
ready to you know take some naps because
it was just intense you know and I
imagine it's hard to um you know gets 10
o'clock 11 o'clock 12 o'clock at night
and you're going I need to go home and
go to bed but there's still people in
there
so you pretty much your your sleep takes
a back seat it does and then you just
kind of are operating on fumes which is
there's a balance there right because
like you know as you know as a team
leader in this you have to realize that
man you gotta you gotta be able to like
give your team a rest
um
so yeah you know here we are assessing
the building of course that was always
the question was is it going to crumble
is it going to shift on us is it going
to fall that was always a big concern so
we always were you know looking at the
Dynamics of the building we had a couple
of trimmers I've never seen people run
so fast in my life and I've never exited
building so fast in my life you know
what I mean like the building starts to
shake and you're like man I do not want
to be in this building everybody Runs
Out jumping out you know where they
could go and uh here's Dylan he's
totally exhausted passed out on a
backboard which have you ever stepped on
the backboard it's awful hard plastic
but it was great man God sent us so many
just neat
that'll hold our
he's from Germany and he had such a neat
testimony like his German team actually
like it was so overwhelming and there
were some political things going on the
German team just like were like nope
we're not going to be helping we're
going to have to just sit it out in the
camp and he was like no I didn't come
all the way here to sit in some Camp
he's like I'm checking out I'm no longer
a soldier I'm a civilian wow and he
literally just walks out of his Camp
finds our team and is like how can I
help and it was awesome and he was he
was a great asset because he could
probably get in trouble for doing that
yeah he was he was like a bricklayer
building engineer like he knew you know
about buildings and stuff so it was just
a great asset to have we had a team of
Turkish miners that showed up and then
if you know anything about digging
underground guess who know guess who has
some skills right some minors right
they're like thousands of feet
underground where things are really
sketchy and so they know how to shore
things up you know like they these guys
when they showed up on scene and there
was some contention between the French
and the miners like the French were like
no we don't need your help you go work
over there yeah you're not seriously
seriously and it really made him upset
because you know they're like this is
our country right and and wow and to
date that the French had pulled nobody
out of the rubble alive these guys had
pulled like 36 people up so like the
score was like 36 to zero you know like
like these guys are like let us in there
and the French were like uh-uh we don't
want you in here like you know we don't
know how you work we don't know if
you're professionally certified you know
off all these things you know and they
were finally we were able to kind of be
the mediator between the French and The
Miser look you guys got to let these
guys do something you know like let them
in there so when they finally let them
in there do these guys dug faster and
quicker than all of us combined like
they were like moles they were just like
you dig into dig into the tunnel but
what was really crazy about this
um this is one of their leaders you know
he was don't take my team he said the
French team don't take my team
he's all frustrated but
no they were away our team is in the
building
and work hard
yeah so and Jesse says the French team
was here they didn't take my team but
now they left and now it's just our team
he's like we're working hard you know so
there's cultural things too you know
like they they and there's a balance
there because they see you know outside
Western help as Colonial you know and so
yeah you have to really be careful of
that and so we really tried to work with
the locals where we could these guys
were amazing we had an awesome
opportunity to pray with these guys
witness to these guys and they were a
blessing to have there but the challenge
was is that every team that came
eventually left like the French came and
said it's impossible or there's just
there's no way there's no way and the
miners eventually got to the same point
they're like we just feel like this
building is way too unsafe
and I think this is part of the story
that I still struggle with because you
know it's like I could see how God was
setting up
this whole story right like like it goes
from none of man's strength or input and
all of a sudden like we get the French
team which is like the epitome of man's
strength and input and the Lord removes
that and then he gives us the miners
which is like hey we'll take them like
you know second string maybe they're
even better and then he removes them and
so it's like God was stripping us away
in fact our dogs our dog team had to
leave they were all getting on their
flights getting ready to go home and so
we were up against the clock like our
flights were literally like the next day
and that was the biggest challenge I was
like what do you do like you know people
are in this building alive
like can you walk away from this
building knowing that somebody's alive
in there
and that was oh man it was just
heart-wrenching because then the doubts
come in you know like the French are
like well we don't think anybody was in
there that's how they justify you know
we don't think anybody was in there you
know
so it was just it was all false false
evidence you know and yet we knew like
God had led us there for a reason right
like all these different things and
um and I can honestly say
our dog's alerted we brought them in for
one last sweep in the basement and our
dogs literally went to this corner and
they were just like I mean hardcore like
barking like this is it right here like
they were and
and then our dog team had to leave so
that was and and man this is where I
really struggle because I should have
just taken that on faith to say okay
this is it like they're right here like
let's if it's just Dylan and I and Luke
the three of us that are left and we're
digging with our hands let's do with our
hands and find it but in a moment of
weakness I I just in my mind I was like
you know what I just I want a second
confirmation there's all these doubts
out there and so we had this Saudi
Arabian team come and they brought their
dogs and um it was really unfortunate
because as soon as they brought the dogs
I knew I had made a mistake because
their dogs were like timid they weren't
as well trained they were like eating
trash in the rubble they didn't want to
perform they're like come on get in
there and the dog was like I'm not going
in there you know and so it was just it
was it was it was like man like I
shouldn't have put any confidence in
this you know and as soon as we were in
there trying to reassess that the
building just began to shake like pretty
big Tremor and we all exited and
um we got out of there
and um
man it was hard because you know part of
our team was leaving and so we took a
break to just go say goodbye to a couple
people this was the lady that we
actually helped look for her kids we
actually sent a team back we found we
found her kids none of them were alive
they were all dead and so we sent the
team back to just help dig the bodies
out of the rubble
and she was so thankful like as she was
leading our team to the site to dig
these children out of the rubble she's
yelling at the top of her lungs and
we're like oh no like what did we do you
know like did we do something wrong did
we step on some toes and the transfers
with us she's like no no she's yelling
at the top of her lungs look at these
people whom you call infidels wow who
come from America
she's like look at these people who've
done more for me and my family than any
of my Muslim family wow
wow so even if you were just there for
that message to be relayed to the people
right yeah and like like
hugged us she was crying on our
shoulders we're crying on her shoulders
you you know she's just she's so
thankful she doesn't speak any English
you know
but she's just saying I'm never gonna
forget you like you guys have done so
much more for me than I could have ever
done for anybody else you know and it
was just it was just this amazing moment
of of of of
the ministry of presence right
like we didn't sit down and give this
lady a Bible study
yeah you just love it you know we didn't
we didn't like say hey like this is the
truth you know like we just we just were
there for her like in her hour of need
we were there for her and man we gained
a friend we gained a family member you
know like she's a family member now like
if we saw her I guarantee you she would
be like that's my family you know
because they came for me in my hour of
need and so here she is you know just so
thankful Mike's telling her I wish I
could bring more
but my heart will never close for you
my prayers
sorry you guys did way more than what
you should have done already so thank
you
you know and pain man you know it's
I don't know how the world can cope with
this kind of death and destruction
without the view
can we hold
you know how hopeless life would seem I
think if you just had nothing
and not a bigger picture to to give you
that sense of hope you know right
you know and in the context we thought
we thought about this a lot for the
people that are buried in this building
you know is
so what if we could have rescued him and
pulled him out
like would it have been an incredible
testimony yeah
been like what
same time you think about
but now they have to continue living in
a world that's so
evil with death and destruction
you know and and I'm not maybe we made
the wrong decision maybe we should have
persevered in faith you know I'm not
saying I'm beyond you know having a weak
moment of like man we should have just
like knocked and kept on knocking ass
and keep on asking but at the same time
like God and His Mercy can work with
even our failures and even every
situation because he's faithful at the
end of the day it doesn't matter what
happens God is faithful like that is a
fact of life like there's never a moment
in which God is Unfaithful he's faithful
and so like in his Mercy he can lay
someone to rest and say it's okay I'm
gonna come pick you up in a minute you
know and that's the hope that we have
right like on a resurrection
Resurrection morning there are going to
be people who are going to be raised to
life because Jesus is going to call him
fourth in the grave and man they rest
now from this awful World in which we
live I mean I don't think you could you
could pull tons of people on the street
like if people were really honest with
you can anybody say this world is just a
peach
um you know it's just like man like like
especially in these situations when you
see so Much Death and destruction like
what is the most merciful thing man the
most mercile thing is just to be resting
in the grave till Jesus comes yeah
so man we we gave these guys hugs and I
don't think I've ever cried so hard in
my life like just because you know the
feeling of knowing like man they're so
close and yet we didn't I didn't come
away with the with the expectation that
I thought that I was going to come away
with you know like in my mind it was
like I want to see people pulled out of
that Rubble alive you know and yet it
didn't happen and uh um here we are in
front of the building the guy on the
left right here
um in the black right there his name is
Anya that was his family that was in the
building
and
I mean just like big bearded Burly
Muslim guy and did he just wept on my
shoulder you know because he knew he
knew we had given everything we could
give humanly speaking like we'd given
everything we possibly could give
and what do you do when you come up
short what do you do when the answer is
no
um
you still trust you still trust just
like job says though you slay me I'll
adjust you yeah you know I never forget
I had I had a friend that um ran over
his child in the driveway and I was one
of the first ones that they called to
come to the house and I distinctly
remember driving over the whole way I'm
just praying in my mind I'm just like
Lord like if now is the time to raise
this child of life it's now like you've
done it before like why not now you know
and man I I got to the house fully like
just like in my mind thinking Lord you
just have to say the word and this child
will live yeah you know and I even went
in the bedroom shut the door kept the
family outside of the bedroom and I just
sat there with this child this lifeless
child
and I just said God please like if it's
your will give this child life Wow and
the answer was no
well
and you look back on that and you think
is it because God doesn't care hmm
and yet I remember holding the father in
the bathroom you know as he's just in
pain like pain that you can't even like
describe he's just rocking back and
forth Just in pain and there's nothing
what can you say what can you say to a
father who's run over their own child
nothing like what are you going to say
it's going to comfort them nothing and
he's just in pain and he's just sitting
there and he says he says I want to do
what it takes
see my kid again oh wow he's like I want
to do what it takes he's like I want to
live a faithful life to God
see my kid again wow and he had been on
a track that had been leading him away
from God he had been on a track that had
been drifting further and further away
from God and it was that signal tragedy
moment that woke him up and brought him
back onto that straight narrow path in
which he was now solidified do you think
I mean he's going to remember that vow
because that vow was paid for with the
life of another wow
greater love has no man than this to
give his life for a friend and it's no
different than the principle in that
situation where a child lost his life so
that his parents would meet him in
heaven wow and it's no different you
know in this situation as well like like
the impact that it made on Anya and his
family
I wish I had the text messages here to
show you this is on your hair the the
arrow and his family I I texted him and
I told him I said I sit on you do you
believe that Jesus could raise your
family to life
and he was like I believe
like I believe and we never gave him a
Bible study the Bible says that Jesus is
the keys to death we never did any of
that all we did was demonstrate that we
were willing to risk Our Lives to try to
save his family and in the end he was
like I believe
and and that's what it takes like in
this day and age in which we live like
man people need to see a sermon yeah
more than they even need to hear a
sermon amen and the same thing with
octai right like octai here he is you
know with us and this is what octai says
this is a text message I actually got
from octai is he is he says I love you
too my brother he said I will be chasing
new Miracles with you guys until my last
breath thank you for your great heart
wow you know I was just like man yeah
God got another one he's got another
worker for his kingdom and octai's mind
is totally blown he said he says you
know I I can't go back to my Muslim
my Muslim religion wow he says because
I've seen something completely different
in Christianity and this is the guy that
you just met on the airplane in the
beginning in the beginning oh wow that
was it that was it
and it's so amazing I wish I could tell
you guys all the amazing that God is
still doing to this day like like
they're they're building a memorial
Center and a training center they're in
Antioch as a result of this whole trip
they're gonna they're gonna save some of
those collapsed buildings and they're
going to turn it into a training center
on the memorial Center for those who
lost their lives and OCTA is now leading
the charge like full on like we're doing
this and he knows that it's for the
purpose of sharing the gospel and that's
and that's you know if that was the
mission that sparked and initiated this
kind of a Ministry to then go and save
in the next disaster or whatever then
you know that God had Purpose with you
being there even though by human
standards people would look at that and
say well you know you didn't save
anybody that would be a failed failed
thing look at how not failed that is
yeah yeah it only makes sense to the
spiritual mind and and we even had a
subsequent trip immediately back where
we sent a team immediately back there
um because the need was so great and
they had just in another whole
incredible miraculous trip where God
just LED them step by step person by
person connect with them a whole a whole
team of theology students from Istanbul
who were asked some questions about
Bible prophecy and asking it was amazing
like like God is so great like he can he
can connect the dots like nobody else
and blow us out of the water and and man
the fact is that we see these things
happening Jesus is coming soon like I
know for a fact that these people who
are who have lost their lives in events
like this they're not going to be
resting in the grave law
like it's not much time and God's gonna
call him forth Jesus is going to call
him for it you know the voice of the
Archangel with the mighty
trumpet man's gonna call him out of the
ground and it's going to be amazing day
to see that there amen so Brad thank you
for sharing this with us I hope that you
guys were all inspired by this story
listen if you want to get involved with
a rescue mission I mean these guys have
story after story after Story like this
they need support they need prayers they
need financial donations these guys need
resources and if you think that this
would be something that you'd like to
investigate a little more I hope you
look up their Ministry what's the
website
gettingrescue.org gideonrescue.org but
keep them in your prayers because these
guys literally are willing to risk their
lives to share the gospel I think it's
something that we should all be doing
and Brock it's always a pleasure to hear
you tell these stories and I'm proud of
you as as an older brother I think it's
awesome to to know that you're out there
on the front lines and it's made a huge
impact even on me
all right thank you guys like this video
share it with someone that you may know
and uh we hope that you guys were
immensely blessed if you would like to
subscribe to our Channel please do
subscribe to our channel that way every
time we have a new video come out you
will know about that video but
ultimately keep our ministry in your
prayers and uh thank you all for your
love and support we'll see you next week
new movies in the history of the world
that have completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled The Matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
thank you
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign